au fil des siècles jeanne a changé de
faciès toujours en fonction du message
que le pouvoir voulait faire passer au
peuple c'est cet incroyable défi les
deux profils qui est mis en évidence
femmes guerrières femme mystique qui
entend des voix des estampes des plâtres
défaillance ou encore ses cartons
esquisse de vitraux pour la cathédrale
sainte croix d'orléans françois sicard
l'illustrent sculpteur tourangeau
l'avait même immortalisé pour un projet
de monument à la gloire de la pucelle
mais qui jamais ne verra le jour
pour la première moitié du 19e siècle
c'est une héroïne
religieuse
qui a sauvé la monarchie donc en perdant
période de restauration monarchique
c'est évidemment une figure importante
mais par exemple après la guerre de 70
c'est la défaite de sedan la figure de
jeanne d'arc s'apparente à la filière de
la revanche
j'aime vivre à une épopée en touraine
chinon sainte-catherine de fierbois tour
bien sûr elle y laissera son empreinte
la touraine sera même le théâtre d'une
célèbre rencontre avec charles vii en 14
129 juste après la levée du siège
d'orléans charles s'apprêtait à gagner
reims pour y être couronné le personnage
de jeanne d'arc est ici représentée en
train de venir chercher
charles vii à loches donc devant la
forteresse de loches pour lui indiquer
le chemin de la bataille
du 15e 20e jeanne aura mobilisé les arts
et les créateurs auront servi leur
héroïne comme celle qui personnifiait la
grande histoire nationale
[Musique]